[Musique]
oui chef oui chef
ça marche ça marche i couvertures et
cagliari tapie a atterri dolan
dégustation trois pièces une fébrilité
de saumon fumé de foie gras chelem
violente et j'en suis à bouger aux
épices un plan sur vos petits pois y
coopère d'agneau
and you there you boys rognant meco et
avons plus à étouffer
[Musique]
quand c'est bon il ya pas meilleur
bonjour c'est ce que nous allons essayer
de réaliser encore aujourd'hui comme
chaque samedi à la même heure
cette semaine nous accueillons joël
rebuchon bonjour joël merci d'être dans
la cuisine de fr3 alors aujourd'hui
quelle est la recette on va commencer il
ya la sade pastorale aux herbes et il ya
le secret de la sauce verjus parce que
le ver jeu c'est la saison où il faut le
récolter avant une petite question vous
êtes cuisinier à paris un grand
restaurant un grand chef
alors comment on fait pour devenir grand
chef qui il a tout raflé joël en
quelques années toutes les plus grandes
distinctions trois étoiles au guide
michelin en trois ans un palmarès de
champion du monde
alors si vous pouvez en quelques mots
nous expliquer comment on fait dans mais
déjà une grande toque ça me rend dit oui
non mais je crois que il faut commencer
son mec est très jeune il faut circuler
il faut apprendre son métier il faut
connaître chaque région vous savez qu'il
ya une cuisine de terre de sienne de mer
vous manger une choucroute en alsace à
n'aura pas le même goût manger en alsace
que manger sur la côte d'azur une
bouillabaisse manger sur la côte d'azur
dans l'open mêmes goûts donc il faut
connaître les produits du terroir chaque
terroir le meilleur produit il faut
aimer son métier essayé d'auxerre
toujours au mieux apprendre mieux alors
le verjus ça consiste en quoi qu'est ce
que c'est les bains le verjus disons que
c'est un raisin qu'on ramasse une fois
les vendanges terminées c'est un raisin
qui n'arrive jamais à maturité qui reste
toujours vert qui est acide et donc ce
qui est intéressant dedans c'est qu'on
obtient toujours des sceaux ceux qui
sont acide amer sucré
là c'est une gratte mais je crois que
une fois les vendanges terminées on peut
rentrer dans certaines propriétés
attention aux coups de fusil c'est quand
même dangereux
mais c'est autorisé vous pouvez
grappillé et ramasser des grains de
raisin que vous allez faut savoir que
les vignerons en plus les laisse dessus
donc on peut la récupérer et ça coûte
rien ça ne gênera en rien les
hectolitres de leur récolte donc le
mieux c'est de faire sans verjus c'est
d'en prendre dans pressé que nous allons
faire d'en récolter d'en mettre dans des
sachets de légumes conservés au
congélateur comme ça on a toujours pour
toute l'année alors montrez moi ça dr
on les a vus mais hélas c'est une phase
war ben ouais il faut que justifie quand
même tenue oui je crois m'être connaît
depuis tellement longtemps que si notre
mal faire des bêtises voilà donc on va
apprécier le jus là on a aussi 150 g de
raisins on va obtenir à peu près quatre
des six litres de jus
alors pour l'instant ce n'est pas encore
du verjus jeu de raisin c'est du jus de
verjux du jus de verjux attention ne pas
confondre le verjus avec le vert on peut
prendre des raisins verts aussi des
raisins blancs louis blanc rouge sapin
d'importance tout ça dépend de la sauce
que l'on veut faire
donc là on va récupérer le jus et on va
donc pendant ce temps-là commencé à
faire étuver les échalotes
est ce que c'est bien tourner chef c'est
bien la machine est absolument
automatique donc alors là il ya peu près
20 g de beurre
j'ai quand même rendre utile je vous
passe les échalotes l'an les échalotes
vous les avez finement haché oui alors
donc on met à des achats directement
dans le beurre qui n'est pas encore son
du mag la valeur de 2 échalotes 2
échalotes dans un peu de beurre qui
n'est pas complètement déchets pour les
empêcher de colorisation des mets dans
le beurre qui a déjà fondu avant coloré
tout signe d'accord et on va mettre le
ciel tout de suite qui va aider à la
cuisson des échalotes
je vous passe le sel est ce que je
pourrais venir travailler avec cuisine
pour vous passer le sel pour passer de
ça c'est déjà très bien je fasse très
bien le fun révélera vite d'autres
maintenant vallée cure tu vois ça colore
pas oui il faut pas qu'un coloré portant
ça cuit vite parce qu'on a mis le dans
froid et on a mis le sel donc à l'heure
froisse l échalote alors donc maintenant
on va rajouter de verjux oui pour gagner
du temps
on en a déjà ses réduiront là c'est
réduire de plus de moitié
donc 4 décidé on part qu'on a servi un
jus de raisin frais on le fait réduire
dans la tombe et d'échalotes avec le
beurre blanc a pas de bêtises pour
l'instant et une fois que ces réduit on
va obtenir ça on va dans même maintenant
voilà n'ai rien compris alors voilà on
rajoute de ce oui d'accord c'est pas du
tout ce que je voulais faire
qui maintenant va laisser réduire alors
on peut là on a gagné du temps mais on
peut prédire le mettre directement comme
ça et c'est réduire sur les échecs alors
une fois qu'on a du verjus
oui qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le verjus
eh bien disons que le verjus c'était
donne des excellentes sauce poissons et
si on veut on peut faire exactement la
même chose pour de la viande mais par
contre la banque ans avait terminé nous
allons l'adoucir nous allons finir le
montant beurre si on veut faire pour de
la viande on met un jus de viande et on
réduit ont fait exactement la même
alors monter au beurre s'est incorporé
un peu de beurre incorporez si pour
l'adoucir parce que c'est très amer très
acide et donc il faut la douche ou bien
quand ça sera réglé ils regardent déjà
la couleur que sa défense on dirait du
caramel mais oui c'est le sucre alors
maintenant on va rajouter le beurre
alors là on rajoute un peu de beurre
alors morceaux en fin de compte si on
réfléchit bien écrit ce que ça ressemble
un petit peu à la technique de me faire
un bourg blanc un beurre fondu
c'est tout simple ouais ça c'est tout
seul et si on prend du raisin de table
s'est pas tout à fait l'avis ouais mais
ce client on n'aura pas l'acidité qui
est intéressant surtout pour le très
intéressant dans le verger c'est la
silice et l'acidité et plus en plus ça
coûte orient leur lancée fondre le
beurre très très lentement rire on
incorpore c'est ce qui va donner une
liaison à la sauce une sauce qui va ta
tion 2,17 sauce se conservent en sachet
le le verjus le verjus donc le verjus
sais je suis j'aurais jamais vous pouvez
le conserver au congélateur sans aucun
problème alors là j'ai incorporé environ
80 g de beurre et que tu laisses encore
rigoler mais tu perds tu verras que
c'est tout simple mais non mais c'est il
faut prendre un torchon non non non non
non parce que j'ai peur de me brûler
sais pas ce qu'a fait la dextérité de
joël robuchon
voilà donc le beurre 5h peur tout seul
tu vas me passer le chinois le chinois
enfin les pingouins l'étamine eh bien
oui
où est l'état mines voilà ce qu'on
appelle regardent comme si ça brille ça
la réussite d'une sauce une source d'eau
est brillante
donc là maintenant quand même on va
rectifier l'assaisonnement
alors un peu de poivre qu'on n'a pas mis
samedi d'un peu de sel
donc ce sont des sauces claque eux qui
sont faites pour le poisson donc vous
asseoir à ses relevés et ensuite nous
allons passer à la pastorale
donc je file chinois qu'est-ce qui n'ont
pas voté très important outil ya plus
rien à rajouter
maintenant on va passer la sauce donc on
va passer la sauce alors ce verjus avec
du poisson ou avec de la viande
également si on a mis du jus de viande
de d'en réduire également avec d'accord
donc c'est tout simple c'est rapide
voilà alors maintenant il y en a environ
pour 4 5 personnes très bien et puis
regarde cette sauce l'onctuosité quand
même ses soutiens douter oui je vais
rapidement parce qu'il faut faire la
salade joël ont l'air en forme
c'est très bon alors quel est le secret
de la pastorale tout en fin de compte
surtout si on est à la campagne
la réussite c'est de ramasser toutes les
herbes du jardin et de tout est mélangé
en fin de compte c'est une salade
d'herbes
est ce que tu nous qui nous tue que nous
présente ces termes là il ya de la nette
du cerfeuil
donc on l'a déjà et que tu es là tu
connais nom de la marjolaine marjolaine
très belles chansons du basilic d'asile
it on trouve ces gerbes surtout les sur
tous les marchés il ya aucun problème de
l'estragon
là on en met un peu moins parce que ça
domine c'est très fort ce sont des
feuilles de menthe la de la sauge de la
mâche de l'assad frisé da trévise et du
cresson et on peut rajouter
après on peut rajouter des pissenlits on
peut rajouter toutes les herbes qu'on
aime et on peut en mettre plus ou moins
sauf en fonction ses goûts ce qu'il faut
chercher dans l'originalité de la salade
c'est d'avoir des salles attendre et des
salades croquantes le secret de la
vinaigrette parce que c'est une émission
qui est à base de secret c'est une
émission qui n'est pas secrète j'espère
que vous me suivez
très facilement alors le secret de la
vinaigrette donc on va commencer par
matin peu de sel pour faire fondre le
sel avec le nail et par là alors vous
prenez du vinaigre de jerez du quart et
choisissez de préférence
oui ça aussi dans deux ans au parlement
du bio on apprend du drs et du vinaigre
de vin vieux alors on va prendre une
cuillère de chaque on a perdu la
cuillère non on va la retrouver peut
prendre le verger ça va donner du goût
non jeu elle est un méticuleux il y suit
tous les instruments
une cuillère à peu près une cuillère de
vinaigre de jerez ou cuillère de
vinaigre de vin une vinaigre vous l'avez
dit une cuillère de vinaigre de vin on
mélange les deux leurs amis d'abord le
sel le sel pour bien le faire fondre
pour quels qu'ils soient est dissout
dedans alors il est recommandé ou c'est
souvent quand on mange de la salade de
chez soi un jour il ya trop de
vinaigrette le lendemain il y en a pas
c'est ce qu'il faut faire faut toujours
faire la vinaigrette à part et
l'incorporer après dans la salade comme
ça on est juste ce qu'il faut alors là
je vous laisse mes cuisses vous voulez
que ça alors là m 3 cuillères et 3
cuillerées une deux trois
alors en fin de compte là je suis
maintenant on n'a rien inventé rien
inventé je crois qu'il ya un petit
secret quand même et que vous allez nous
l'avons démonté il ya des secrets au
poivre un peu de poids et maintenant ce
qui va faire la différence avec une
vinaigrette normal c'est qu'on va
récupérer la mettre dedans du jus de
rôti
alors ça peut être et voilà le secret du
jus de rôti vous avez tous du jus de
rôti vous faites des rôtis dureté
douceur du jus de volaille le meilleur
après le gic peur c'est le meilleur
temps là vous l'avez fait chauffer tout
est donc mis les pieds d'un donc là ce
soir et a voulu incorporer ella ella
devoir mettre une cuillère
oui non une cuillérée de jus de volaille
dans votre vinaigrette
[ __ ] de comme il est beau on va mettre
un peu plus il est magnifique mais tu va
remuer pendant ce temps là mais je vais
remuer oui je crois qu'on va et puis on
va mélanger toutes les salades on va
mélanger toutes les salades
alors dans la salle hurle à salhab la
trêve nice alors vous faites votre
mélange de salade
moi je continue de tourner la
vinaigrette c'est tout à fait facile
je crois que je fais assez doué pour ça
des combats dimanche
joël est très rigoureux avec ses
apprentis cuisiniers convaincant qu'il
ya des propensions mais les proportions
faut les mettre en fonction de ses goûts
et vous ramassez les salades vous
mélangez que l'herbe que vous aimez
alors joël je vais vous mettre à
contribution vous allez assaisonner la
salade
oui allez-y parce que cette recette et
sur minitel
vous composez le code 36,5 36,15 pardon
peac3 et nous serons heureux de vous
adresser cette re recettes sur votre
minitel la semaine prochaine nous allons
accueillir un autre grand chef dans
votre cuisine et dans la nôtre c'est à
dire que nous recevrons josé lampre ya
qui vous donnera tous les secrets de la
purée une bonne purée c'est pas mauvais
et je crois même que ça peut
s'accommoder avec de la salle sur votre
très bien ensemble
alors si on veut rehausser la salade
quand même on peut rajouter un peu tout
ça c'est que peut-être il s'intéressa
culte hâtif parce que au prix de la
truffe
ça fait très cher la salade mais c'était
la petite fantaisie de joël rebuchon
donc rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour un grand chef dans votre cuisine et
joël quand c'est bon sopat meilleurs
voilà tout
[Musique]